[SPEAKER_01]: Paul Ribeiro and his men walk into the building.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you basically say straight and do you want him to just keep going straight or do you want, what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to walk in with him?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: How many Marines are behind me?
[SPEAKER_01]: You have 30 Marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: 20 stayed with the fire.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, let's go in.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so he walks in.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he walks in and he's like, God!
[SPEAKER_01]: Be quiet, you say.
[SPEAKER_01]: You walk up next to him, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Smack the shit up.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are people moving all over here.
[SPEAKER_01]: The guards come in behind you, but you can tell they're like freaked out by what they see.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want these people to be held here for interrogation later.
[SPEAKER_01]: The sergeant says, you ten men, spread out, take them prisoner.
[SPEAKER_01]: One of the men says,
[SPEAKER_01]: Are they worth being prisoners, sir?
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, Paul Rivera orders it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have a tin with me.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't see anybody here that is wearing that mask.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, they have hollow eyes, very pale.
[SPEAKER_01]: Their hair seems to be falling out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Their teeth seems to be falling out.
[SPEAKER_01]: A bunch of methods.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's kind of like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Next room.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you keep walking down straight this way, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: The guy's behind you.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you and the sergeant come to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I see it open to a door over here.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you walk back that way and
[SPEAKER_01]: You see the two burly guys, right there, stand up with their blades out, ready.
[SPEAKER_01]: One of them says to the other one, It's the young prince!
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you say?
[SPEAKER_01]: Kill them!
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm gonna kill you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you say to your guys, Kill him!
[SPEAKER_00]: Kill them!
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, roll an ish.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, fifteen plus four is nineteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nineteen?
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, you and your men get the jump.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you get to go first.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, I want to shoot... Yeah, use my light crossbow.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to nail him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so, just that one?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you just go and fire at him.
[SPEAKER_01]: He has not had an action in combat yet, so... Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You get an advantage on this shot.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sweet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, let's try this again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, you don't get a critical automatically because he's not surprised.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, he's been waiting.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he hasn't had a chance yet, so you get to roll two 20s.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Seventeen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Seventeen plus your, what's your... Dexterity is four, so it's... No, no, it's your crossbow attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, crossbow attack is plus six.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, seventeen... That's like... Twenty-three.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, twenty-three.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, you hit him.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's one die eight plus your...
[SPEAKER_00]: Dexterity?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, four plus four is eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I gotta start recording this stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, your bolt hits the guy in the arm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which arm?
[SPEAKER_00]: The arm he's wielding?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And... Um... A black...
[SPEAKER_01]: Blood begins to run down his side.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your sergeant runs to here with his sword.
[SPEAKER_01]: You get to make the attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll the attack for him.
[SPEAKER_01]: A 20-sided die.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nat 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nat 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: That is two die eight plus three.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight plus three is eleven points.
[SPEAKER_01]: And basically attacks him and does damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: The other guys file behind you.
[SPEAKER_01]: One here, one here, one here, one here, one around you here.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four.
[SPEAKER_01]: One will make it to there, another one will make it to there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And, um, so that's one, two, two guys on hand, two more guys on hand.
[SPEAKER_00]: Take the one with the crossbow in the arm alive if you can.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so do you want to attack him now?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or grapple him?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I yell that clear and loud as day to my Marines.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's down in here?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's going to be next round.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to take some guys and I want to go in here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you can move if you want to stay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I want to let them deal with that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I want to go into the next room.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're going to be really quick with this.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can come to here.
[SPEAKER_00]: You see the woman right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_01]: She's got this dagger.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want your guys to attack?
[SPEAKER_00]: Kill him, keep him alive.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, do the attacks on that guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fourteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: One die eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seven plus three is ten.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then this guy on hand.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nine plus three.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Attacks back.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy attacks him twice.
[SPEAKER_01]: First attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fourteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: He attacks him again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twelve plus four is a sixteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's a miss, too.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy attacks the sergeant twice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three miss, ten miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, they're fighting, but it's not doing anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, roll the niche for the next round.
[SPEAKER_00]: Twelve plus four is sixteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: 17th.
[SPEAKER_00]: I get to go first.
[SPEAKER_01]: She pulls out a scimitar and comes to here and attacks you twice.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's your AC?
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, sixteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sixteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, you, no, you attacked.
[SPEAKER_01]: You attacked.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so here's the first attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight, miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't have a shield, do you?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you basically knock that away with your crossbow.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, here's our next attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sixteen plus five, that's a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three, and she basically goes across your shoulder with the blade, cutting into your leather and doing six points of damage to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: With the scimitar?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Six points of damage?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so I'm at 21 HP.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, your turn.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, I'm gonna ditch my, like, crossbow and I'm gonna pull out my short sword.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll your attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: Seven plus four is... Eleven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so that misses.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to move at all?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'm gonna back up, or disengage and just back up a little bit.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you can use your bonus action to disengage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And how far do you want to back up?
[SPEAKER_01]: Just right here, so next to this marine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, and so you back up to here, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: The power of arrow disengages.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I say, take her alive!
[SPEAKER_01]: We need her!
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy runs to here and attacks.
[SPEAKER_00]: Awesome.
[SPEAKER_00]: Love these marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: A marine runs to here from back in the room.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do the attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven plus five.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: One die eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's only two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two, that's five.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: A Nash.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two plus four is six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight, so they get to go first.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy attacks that guy twice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seventeen, that's a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: It does three, four, five,
[SPEAKER_01]: Six.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to use the guards here.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I'm going to leave that alone.
[SPEAKER_01]: Use the guards here.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then he attacks him again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Four.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seven, eight, nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so he slashes that guy's throat.
[SPEAKER_00]: Someone's dying.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he falls on the ground.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy attacks the sergeant.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eighteen hits.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two misses.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here's the hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: He does four, five, six, seven.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sergeant has seven off him.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
[SPEAKER_01]: She attacks this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: First points.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thirteen, eighteen, that's a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: It does four, five, six, seven.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's number two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nineteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: He doesn't fall, but he's wounded.
[SPEAKER_01]: This Marine moves to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Another Marine takes the place.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy moves to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I need some more Marines in here.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy disengages with his action and falls back to here, okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to tell this guy, get in there?
[SPEAKER_00]: Get in there, and I want to, can I shoot a crossbow at her?
[SPEAKER_01]: You can, but if this guy gets in there, you can basically also do a sneak attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that one has to be a melee attack to do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can fire first if you want.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I want to fire a crossbow.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you fire your crossbow at her.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's gonna be nine plus four, which is fourteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thirteen, but that is a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: One die eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Five plus four is nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you shoot at her, and she kind of knocks the bolt away, but it still hits her and picks her like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's nine?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want her alive.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy moves into there with his sword and attacks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lovely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll the attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sixteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three plus three is six.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy attacks him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll the attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: Six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_00]: This guy attacks him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nineteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nineteen, that's a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll one die eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two, that's five.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy attacks him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ten, that's a hit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight, nine, ten, eleven.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so that's thirty.
[SPEAKER_01]: The sergeant attacks him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Three.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy attacks him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_00]: One die eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: One.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's four.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, and then that last guy attacks him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Put her down.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's twelve.
[SPEAKER_00]: Twelve, that's a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Put him down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, that's a one.
[SPEAKER_01]: One.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two, three, four.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: These guys stab this guy repeatedly several times.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he is tough.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, they're striking him.
[SPEAKER_01]: He takes probably twice the amount of blows that normal man would.
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys are coked up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he does fall.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: But you can tell your guys are like freaked out.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's like on the ground writhing and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy is still doing his thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy is facing this moment.
[SPEAKER_01]: One-on-one, the baddest motherfucker in here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, Anish.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nat 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys get to go first.
[SPEAKER_00]: Awesome.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you want him to take...
[SPEAKER_00]: I want him alive, and I want her alive.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want your guy to attack, or what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: I want more Marines to flood in this room.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, you're just like, more Marines!
[SPEAKER_01]: Get in there!
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, do you want this guy to try and push her back?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's a strength against strength.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's got a strength of 16, so he gets a plus three.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's an athletics roll, he gets a plus five, and she has a...
[SPEAKER_01]: She has a plus three.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So... Fifteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fifteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: He pushes her back to here, shoving her back with his shield before he moves in to here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, this guy is going to stay where he is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to come in?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I want to get in.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to get right next to her?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you come to here, and do you want to attack?
[SPEAKER_01]: Follow your attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nat won.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, if you are, hang on, let me see what this says.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um...
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know, don't do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you get a nat 1.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dex check DC 10.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, 10 plus 4, 14.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You stumble.
[SPEAKER_01]: And fall to your knees right there over some debris.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're basically on the ground.
[SPEAKER_01]: Another guy comes in behind you.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four.
[SPEAKER_01]: To here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: She takes her scimitar and she's going to attack you with advantage.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's great.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, that means she gets two 20-sided die.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here's the attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: 18 and 8.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they're 18.
[SPEAKER_01]: That 18 nails me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Question.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to use your underdog to make the advantage, disadvantage?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you use that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And knock her blade away with that attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Surprising her.
[SPEAKER_00]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_01]: Even though you're on the ground.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now remember that ability.
[SPEAKER_01]: The thing about that ability is if they have advantage, they roll first, and then you get to make the choice.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that's the thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: So you manage to get her blow away.
[SPEAKER_01]: That guy goes there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nish.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ten plus four.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fourteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys get to go first.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy tries to grapple her.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he grabs onto her.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's got to roll his attack and hit her, and then it's strength to strength.
[SPEAKER_01]: So go ahead and roll the attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two.
[SPEAKER_01]: He misses.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy moves around to here to crowd her and tries to grapple her.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll his attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: Seventeen.
[SPEAKER_01]: He grabs onto her with his hands and holds her like a marine should.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy grabs onto him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll the attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_01]: And grabs onto him and this guy starts pummeling him.
[SPEAKER_01]: So roll the attack for that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy starts pummeling him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fifteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fifteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so he hits.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he does one die plus three, four damage to him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it a 1d8?
[SPEAKER_01]: When you punch somebody, it's one damage plus your strength.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: So the sergeant comes in, and these guys just start beating this dude's ass.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just dogpile.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like they do in The Harbinger.
[SPEAKER_00]: They just start punching that guy down.
[SPEAKER_00]: I love it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're right there, she's still up, but he's got her grappled, but she's struggling with her cutlass.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, do you want to attack her?
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: Grapple.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's got her.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then I want to knock her out.
[SPEAKER_01]: So do you want to, like, palm her as well?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you attack with advantage when you do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sweet.
[SPEAKER_00]: So roll two 20s.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fifteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then...
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if you want to, you can do a sneak attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like hit her in a vulnerable area.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, totally.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you want to do the sneak attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: That does... What that's going to do, though...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's gonna do two points of damage instead of one, plus two dice six, plus your strength.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it'll do four plus two dice six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: One.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you basically hit her in the chest with your short sword and say, give up!
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically.
[SPEAKER_01]: And she tries to stab that guy with her cutlass.
[SPEAKER_01]: Five, and misses.
[SPEAKER_01]: Her blade moving across his scale mail.
[SPEAKER_01]: She attacks him again, trying to strike him in the leg.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seven, misses.
[SPEAKER_01]: Scale mail is not the best, but it seems to be doing right.
[SPEAKER_01]: A niche.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eighteen plus four is twenty-two.
[SPEAKER_01]: One.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're going to attack her again?
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to knock her out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sneak attack also?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you want to pummel though.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're not using your blade.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't want to kill her.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I don't want to kill her.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll the attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: Three.
[SPEAKER_00]: With advantage?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that's with advantage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fourteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fourteen plus your dexterity.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think it's plus six with your blade, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: With my blade, yeah, plus six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's gonna be two, four, plus two dice six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Three, one.
[SPEAKER_00]: So four plus four is eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, two, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you hit her in the chest again.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy is gonna hit her.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll for a pun.
[SPEAKER_00]: Three.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy is grappling.
[SPEAKER_01]: She's gonna try and break the grapple.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here's her roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll his strength check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_01]: He basically keeps a hold of her.
[SPEAKER_00]: Awesome.
[SPEAKER_01]: She tries to attack him again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twelve.
[SPEAKER_00]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_00]: Again.
[SPEAKER_00]: Seventeen.
[SPEAKER_01]: She does hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that's three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that takes... One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your guard says, Goddamn tough bitch!
[SPEAKER_01]: Knock her out, Romero!
[SPEAKER_01]: Anish.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: 10 plus 4 is 14.
[SPEAKER_00]: You win.
[SPEAKER_00]: Awesome.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, same thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you're just basically...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm...
[SPEAKER_01]: Die!
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, that's gonna be a six and... another six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, six and six.
[SPEAKER_01]: You miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: You basically are messing with her.
[SPEAKER_01]: He punches her.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three.
[SPEAKER_00]: This guy has rolled three, three times in a row.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, basically...
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't know what's happening behind you, but you feel more Marines crowding in behind you, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And... Everyone just kind of dawgs.
[SPEAKER_01]: You feel the sergeant's hand on your shoulder and says, Paul, Rivera, come back!
[SPEAKER_01]: And he kind of pulls you back as she like, is like spitting and...
[SPEAKER_01]: Kind of making these weird hissing noises, but he gets you out of the way, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And he lets his marines pile into the room and just start beating on her.
[SPEAKER_01]: You see one of these guys on the ground just bleeding out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviously, it's this guy where they killed him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Stabbed multiple times with swords.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy's on the ground and the marines are standing on him.
[SPEAKER_01]: One of them is taking manacles and locking his
[SPEAKER_01]: Hands behind him.
[SPEAKER_01]: He pulls the mask off the guy's face, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And you look at this dude in the moonlight, because there are holes in the center, you can see.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he looks at you, and he's got these strange, fang-like teeth, either filed or natural.
[SPEAKER_01]: He doesn't look quite human.
[SPEAKER_01]: The thing that really gets you, though, is his slit-like eyes.
[SPEAKER_00]: With his mask?
[SPEAKER_01]: Vertical slits.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, they pulled the mask off him.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he looks like a man.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, his face is very angular and bone-shaped.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the eyes, the eyes strike you because you know who else has eyes like that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Snake eyes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's strange.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anyway, the fighting continues in there.
[SPEAKER_01]: You back up and look as these guys basically pull him up.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's just hissing and biting at people, but they've got him.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they start checking him out.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the sergeant just sits there as these dudes beat down who plays in that room.
[SPEAKER_01]: The fighting goes on for probably about a minute.
[SPEAKER_01]: And one of your guys kind of walks out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviously wounded.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he's like, ah, she's tough.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you can tell he's been bitten on his arm, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Psycho.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two bite holes there.
[SPEAKER_01]: The sergeant goes, she'll be down soon.
[SPEAKER_01]: What shall we do with the prisoners?
[SPEAKER_00]: The prisoners that we took role?
[SPEAKER_01]: The people in there are
[SPEAKER_01]: Worthless.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, we can take them if you wish.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just want to question them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Understood.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll take all of them back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or do you wish us to take them to the Harbor District or to the Royal?
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll be safer in the Royal Dungeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Understood, sir.
[SPEAKER_00]: What can I do to thank you for your services today, Marines?
[SPEAKER_01]: Just help our good service to the city, sir.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it shall be done.
[SPEAKER_00]: What is your name?
[SPEAKER_01]: Perhaps an extra barrel of ale for the 4th Wharf Marine Barrack?
[SPEAKER_00]: As you wish.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was with the Marines on Helm Deep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or on Helm... What was it about?
[SPEAKER_00]: It was at Helm's...
[SPEAKER_00]: Helm's Island.
[SPEAKER_00]: One of the great fighters.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm sorry for your losses.
[SPEAKER_01]: You must come down to the barracks when you can and tell us the tales.
[SPEAKER_01]: You'll be welcome there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I shall.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what do you want to do now?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sir, I ask that you lead us out of here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, I will.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the Marines, with their two wounded, because they have two guys that were, none of your guys got killed.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, one was very badly wounded by that scimitar.
[SPEAKER_01]: The other one was badly wounded by her dagger.
[SPEAKER_01]: And helping their wounded comrades out, the group of 30 men walk through the Warrens with you and the sergeant at the head.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Back to where the alchemist place is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: You see Rodiger there with the ten men and actually more have come, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: You and your troops file out of the building with the disgusting group of slimoids.
[SPEAKER_01]: The undesirable.
[SPEAKER_01]: The meth heads.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the two prisoners that are still now kind of hissing and cursing as they get lead in irons through the warrants.